in this video you're going to learn how
to do Gaussian elimination with back
substitution so this is just another
technique for solving systems of
equations instead of doing the graphing
method or the elimination method of the
substitution method now we're using
basically like a matrix method and again
it's called Gaussian elimination with
back substitution where to go through
two examples the first example you can
see we've got three equations three
variables our first step is to write it
as an Augmented matrix so what is an
Augmented matrix well essentially what
an Augmented matrix is is you're just
using the coefficients okay the numbers
in front of the variables and you're
also adding on the solutions here in
this for this right column so what all
I'm doing is I'm just writing down those
coefficients writing down the answers
okay and you can see I'm separating with
little line or dashed line okay like so
and the way that Gaussian elimination
works is that you can interchange any
two rows okay you can multiply any row
by a constant as long as it's not zero
and you can add any two rows together so
let's see if I can show you how this
works our first step is we're going to
try to get 0 in this lower left-hand
corner and the way I'm going to do that
is going to multiply the first row by
negative 1 and I'm going to add it to
the third row I'm going to put the
answer in the third row now I want to
warn you right from the very beginning
it's good to make a little note about
what you're doing in case you make a
mistake and you want to go back and
track you know the steps that you did
it's very easy to do there's a lot of
just like little arithmetic errors that
can happen but let me see if I can show
you so negative 1 okay plus 1 gives us 0
negative 2 plus 4 is 2 positive 3 plus
negative 2 is 1 and negative 1 plus 9 is
8 okay the other two rows are staying
the same so I'm just going to copy those
down as they were okay and let's see so
now the next step is we want to get 0 in
this position right here and the way I'm
going to do that is I'm going to
multiply negative 2 times Row one I'm
going to add that to Row 2 and I'm going
to put the answer in Row two ok so let's
go ahead and do that now we're going to
multiply negative 2 times 1 which is
negative 2 plus 2 is 0 negative 4 plus
negative 1 is negative 5 6 plus 1 is 7
and negative 2 plus 1 is negative 1 so
you really have to be careful with
arithmetic because if you make a little
mistake it's going to throw the whole
system off okay so now we've got zero in
these two spots here our next step is to
get zero right here okay and the way
that I'm going to do that is I'm going
to multiply the row 2 by 2 so 2 times
Row 2 and then I'm going to add it to 5
times Row 3 I'm going to put the answer
in Row 3 ok so they're with me so far
so let's go ahead and do that so we're
going to say 2 times Row 2 okay so
that's going to be 0 and then this is
going to be let's see negative 10 plus
positive 10 that's going to give us 0
okay good and then this is going to give
us 14 plus 5 is 19 right and then over
here we've got negative 2 plus 40 which
is 38 ok now the other roles they don't
change they're staying the same so I'm
just going to copy those down it's a lot
of a lot of writing but the nice thing
is you don't have to write the variables
over and over again so now you can see
we've gotten zeros here in this lower
left-hand corner the next step is you
want to get ones on the diagonal okay so
you're with me so far you want to get
ones on this diagonal so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to multiply 119th
times Row three I'm going to put that
answer in Row three I'm also going to
multiply negative 1/5 times Row two and
I'm going to put the answer in Row two
and then the first one is already starts
with the 1 so we're good there
so let me go ahead and do that next step
here so that's going to give us let's
see what we have here we've got 1 2
negative 3 1 ok and we've also got 0 1
and let's see negative 7/5 and we're
multiplied by negative 1/5 so this is
1/5 and let's see what else do we have
we've got 0 0 1 & 2 okay so now if you
can see what we've got so far
this we're going to rewrite these as
equations now so this is actually the
top equation is 1 X plus 2 y minus 3 Z
equals 1 the second equation is 0
Oh X plus 1 y minus 7 5 z 7 v z equals
1/5 and the last one is 1 z is equal to
2 so now here's where the back
substitution comes in you see this kind
of stair step pattern we've got one
variable one equation you know get the
second equations got two variables the
top equations got three variable so
we're just going to back substitute so
if I put two in for Z okay we already
know what Z is we've got Y minus seven
fifths times two equals 1/5 so that's
going to be Y minus 14 fifths equals 1/5
and if we add the 14 fist to the other
side we get 15 fists which equals 3 okay
so now we know what Z and Y are we just
have to solve for X let's go to the top
equation we've got X plus 2 times 3
because that's what Y is minus 3 times 2
that's what Z is equals 1 so we've got X
plus 6 minus 6 is equal to 1 the 6 and
the negative 6 cancel so you can see x
equals 1 and if you want to write your
final answer you would write it as a
triple X is 1 Y is 3 Z is 2 that's your
answer and then you can check your
answer if you want by taking you know
these values x y&z putting them into all
three of the equations here making sure
that you know they give us the
appropriate solutions on the right so
again this is you know Gaussian
elimination with back substitution we're
going to go through another example to
show you more how it works but before I
do that if you're preparing for the AC T
or the SAT you know check out my huge
SAT math review video course on my huge
AC t-- math review video course they go
through a lot of different concepts we
have a teaching segment there's
opportunities to practice and do some
problems and it just gives you a good
overall review and an insight into some
of the key things that they want you to
know when you're taking that test so
definitely check that out I have a link
below in the description and also you
can check out the links through my about
page on my youtube channel Myers math
tutoring but let's get into the next
example let me erase this board and I'll
be right back at you
ok example number two we you can see
we've got a three by three okay three
variables three equations and the first
thing we want to do is worried our
Augmented matrix so let's go ahead and
do that so we're just using the
coefficients the numbers in front of the
variable
right and let's see 1 3 1:18 we've got
some larger numbers here so we might
have to take out the calculator to do
some of these calculations okay to make
it go little bit quicker but remember
our first step here is to get 0 in this
lower left-hand corner and the way we do
that is we want to combine either the
first with the third or the second with
the third I'm just going to take
negative 2 times Row 2 plus Row 3 I'm
going to put the answer in Row 3 ok so
if we do that I'm just going to copy
down I usually like to kind of write
down the rows that haven't changed just
to kind of get that out of the way and
so now this is the row that's going to
be changing Row 3 so negative 2 times 1
is negative 2 plus 2 is 0 negative 6
plus negative 1 is negative 7 negative 2
plus negative 2 is negative 4 and
negative 36 plus negative 3 is negative
39 okay so you can see the numbers are
getting large here okay the next step we
want to get 0 right here where that one
is and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to combine the first equation with
the second equation so that's going to
be negative let's see negative 4 times
Row 2 plus Row 1 answer goes in Row 2
alright so let's go ahead and do that so
we've got let's see a copy down this
bottom row because that's not changing
yeah and again be careful that you don't
make a little simple mistakes because
that's easy to do with this method ok
and so let's see so we've got negative 4
times this role plus this road so that's
going to give us 0 negative 12 plus 1 is
negative 11 negative 4 plus negative 1
is negative 5 negative 4 is going to
give us negative 72 plus 2 12 is
negative 60 okay so now we've got zero
in this spot this spot now we want to
get 0 over here where the negative 7 is
and so the way I'm going to do that is
I'm going to combine the second row with
the third row now you might be thinking
well why aren't you combining the first
with the third well if I combine the
first of the third what's going to
happen is you're going to end up getting
a constant besides zero in this lower
left-hand corner which is going to kind
of reverse out what we you know did
earlier when we try to get 0 here so
that's why I'm just combining the second
in the third because you can see when
you add 0 and 0 that's just going to
still be 0 so it's not going to get rid
of this 0 in this place here so let's go
ahead and figure this one out we're
going to have to let's see multiply 7
times Row 2 right plus a negative 11
times Row 3 and we're going to put the
answer in Row 3 okay so let's go ahead
and do that so we've got 4 we've got one
we've got negative 1 we've got 12 right
and let's see this one is going to stay
the same so 0 negative 11 negative 5
negative 60 this one is going to be
let's see 7 times Row 2 that's negative
77 plus positive 77 that's 0 we've got
negative 35 okay plus 44 which is how
much that's 9 right and then we've got
let's see here's where I'm going to
break out the calculator we've got 7
times Row 2 so that's going to be
negative 4 20 right plus a negative 11
times a negative 39 which gives us 9
okay so that worked out nice ok so there
we go so now you can see we've gotten
zeros in that lower left-hand corner the
next step is to get ones on the diagonal
okay so the way I'm going to do that I
was going to multiply 1/9 times Row
three I'm going to put the answer in Row
three I'm going to multiply Row two
times negative one 11th and I'm going to
put the answer in of course Row two and
then Row one we're going to multiply by
1/4 and I'm going to put the answer in
Row one so I'm just multiplying through
by the reciprocal of the leading
coefficient for that row so if I do that
let me switch over here now okay
we've got on the bottom row we've got 0
0 1 and 1 okay and in the second row
we've got 0 1 let's see 5 11 and let's
see this is going to give us 60 over 11
and then we've got one 1/4 let's see
negative 1/4 and 3 okay so our equations
now are going to be
let's see we've got the top row which is
X plus 1/4 Y minus 1 for Z is equal to 3
we've got 1 y plus 5 11 Z is equal to 60
11s right and then the last one we can
see that we have Z equals 1 so we've
already got Z solve for so that's good
now we're going to do our back
substitution so if I put 1 in for Z that
gives us y + 5 11 s is equal to 60 11 s
subtract the 5 11 s and that gives us Y
is equal to 55 11 s which is equal to 5
ok so we know what Y is now now we have
to solve for X let's put those other
values in we've got X plus 1/4 times y
which is 5 let's see plus a negative 1/4
Z which is 1 is equal to 3 so this gives
us five fours - 4/4 which is negative
4/4 which is I said that wrong 5/4 minus
1/4 is 4 force which is 1 so that's X
plus 1 is equal to 3 if we subtract 1 we
get X is equal to 2 and if we write our
final answer as a triple we've got X is
2 y is 5 and Z is 1 and that's our
answer and again if you want to check
your you know to make sure you did it
right you can take these values put them
in for XY and Z and all three equations
and you know verify that you've done it
correctly and that's exactly right so
this is how to do the Gaussian
elimination with back substitution I'm
going to have another video where we do
the Gauss Jordan elimination with the
row reduced echelon form so if you're
interested take a look at that video and
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
check out more math tutoring videos on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
I look forward to helping you in the
future videos and I'll talk to you soon